bookstores this coming week and watch
for the authors in the near future on
book TV North Korean defector Yami Park
is next on book TV she describes her
experience escaping into China being
sold into slavery and then finding
freedom in South Korea
all right hello everyone thank you so
much for coming to tonight's event just
have a few announcements before we begin
please take this moment to silence your
cellphone's I also want to let you know
you can always keep up with our comings
and goings at Cowels calm or we have
printout calendars and every information
desk for your information c-span will be
filming this event and your image may be
captured your presence here indicates
your permission for it to be filmed
because we are being filmed when it gets
to the question and answer portion of
the event please raise your hand and
wait for the man with the microphone to
come by in order to ask your question I
also have announcements about the store
due to a technical need of moving to a
new website platform house books is
closing early tonight we expect this to
be a lively discussion and we are not
asking anyone to leave early but our
kills will close down promptly at 8:55
so we're asking that all purchases be
made by 8:45 the bathrooms will also
close at 8:45 tonight tonight we are
very happy to welcome youngmee park with
her memoir in order to live a north
korean girls
journey to freedom she was born in North
Korea under the rule of King Jamil where
she spent much of her childhood hungry
and fear of the government's controlling
rule and with only a knowledge of what
state-controlled media told her at the
outside world at 13 her family made a
daring escape into China but then she's
been faced further challenges from being
sold to traffickers to having to cross
the gobi desert into mongolia before
finding freedom in south korea her new
memoir which Kirkus Reviews calls an
elegant wrenchingly honest works that
vividly represents the plight of many
North Koreans details all these
struggles and her new life as a human
rights activist giving speeches too
crowded auditoriums and cities around
the world tonight's event will include
an Oscar Oscar author question and
answer as I mentioned earlier and then
she will be up here to sign books for
you when that time comes please line up
on the left hand side of the room we
have books available for purchase on the
cart right there thank you so much for
coming to Palace for tonight's event now
please welcome you only
park me I'm very short so the worry the
what if I cannot be spin but thank you
so much I'm really honored to be here I
just cannot believe this I am really in
the top biggest independent bookstore in
the US and I never seen this many books
in my life so yeah I don't know very
humbling you know lots of things if you
have you had this access to all these
books and you knew you know a lot of
things so I don't know what can I tell
you something that you never knew before
I'm here to tell you today about the
people I'm not going to talk about
politics and I'm not going to talk about
how strong Kindle enthusiam or what kind
of nuclear weapon he has I'm just here
to talk about the true heart of North
Korea the people just like us who's
trapped in that country for almost 70
years
oh I just I wasn't remembering my life
in North Korean and I remember it I was
not only not freed physically but I was
now free emotionally there is true
difference of dictatorship in North
Korea one physical dictatorship that you
are not allowed to real earrings you are
not allowed to virgins and you are not
allowed to go to Nexus City without
permission and you are not allowed to
watching movies you are not allowed to
listen to songs and you only have one
channel on TV tell you and how great
about how great the regime is and the
other the other dictatorship in your
screw that exists that is emotional
dictatorship disk imaging controls
emotions in the country
and they teach us that they are taught
so the very first thing my mom told me
was not to even whisper because the
birds and mice can't even hear you and I
believed in the words have ears and I
thought my dear leader Kim Jong I can't
read my thoughts so he can read my mind
and he would punish me fight think of
him Natalie so from the very very
beginning I was not a lot of thinking
for myself I didn't even know what
independent thinking or critical
thinking was that was something we never
known and we never a lot known of course
I never turned off I was going to be in
this place there like in millions of
books here and in front of you because
the very difference when I was in North
Korea I never knew how many countries
were existed in the world I never knew
what saddle I was now because I never
knew what internet was and I only
believed was school teacher Tommy and I
never they never told me about the
Africa or Canada Australia but they told
me our enemies forever and my mm is a
very clear and very simple one American
bastards and one the other one Japanese
in Paris and South Korea colonized by
American bastards
so we helped to freedom and this pastor
is trying to attack us at every moment
so we need our dear leader to defenders
because America batters they have big
nose and they have blue eyes and they
are cold-blooded people and they are
monsters I never knew how to I was
America was I really thought all signals
and provides people walking away and
consistent but so many diversity in this
country
I cannot believe them and I learned math
at school and the math problem was like
this there are forming ambassadors and
UQ of them now how many American bus is
left secure
that was my question and you can see me
I'm here today and for my enemies so you
never know is its life you really never
know and the execution poverty
starvation operation its or the part of
North Koreans life
we don't know things can be different
with all to see how life has it been
with all this is how life's supposed to
be we cannot think of a different
possibility life can be different
because we are now allowed to watching
foreign movies from DVDs for information
and also you are not allowed to read
books like here you are not allowed to
buy Axman Batman all the philosophers I
didn't know what like philosophy was or
evolution all I knew was how our dear
leader Kim il-sung free the whole
humanity as after the during the second
world war ii war I believe the his with
all the humanity and he brought all the
kids to this world and that was my
worldview and they told me there's
nothing to ending this world we are the
best country on earth and everybody
wants to be like us and they want to
come to our country and I will sing the
songs
nothing clamping the world power the
only life was not that clear it was not
really paradise he was living here I
worry I remember because I was born in
1993 and after Soviet Union collapsed
there was stopped providing food to
North Korea and that's how those crew
stopped the Russian system and they only
give some food to the early people in
town young and in the country rest of
people they were discriminated by the
regime
that's how during the 1995 to 1998 we
say some differences 3 million people
died and total population was 22 million
to 24 million
and you can imagine how many people died
during that time every household almost
lost their family members include mine
one day I was very young and I saw my
grandma was taking out the medicines and
I was asking her grandma why you're
taking so many medicines and she was
telling me I was some rest and she was
59 American age very young and after a
few hours later I hear that I heard my
uncle was screaming and asking my
grandma to wake up and that's how she
ended her life before the famine gets
her and their bodies on the street that
was something normal for us that was
something not like I didn't feel it was
odd and nobody told me what compassion
was there's no word for freedom in North
Korean Tears know all the fortune and
whites and there's no water for love
only love we can express in that country
is a love for the regime I couldn't ever
imagine I could tell my mom I love you
I never so my father was telling my
mother I love you
everybody had to plan and to promise
that they was willing to die for the
vision and there is no daylight moment
to you the black DVDs came from China to
North Korea and I have some assets to
offer the median but this sector can
give care people North Korean people the
regime killing people with a gun fire
for watching DVDs and for getting access
to these foreign DVDs but luckily I
didn't get caught and I watched the
fallen DVDs and I watched ww7 at anode
0:07 the action movie and I thought okay
American shooting each other all the
time and they climbed the tall buildings
I don't know how they do it by
candlelight there I later
I saw WWF pro wrestling and
thought that's all how American men
looked alike I was so disappointed
insisted and I saw the movie Titanic I
know you're another movie it's a grand
movie but you mean I couldn't process it
when I saw the movie I was shocked how
somebody dared to make a movie out of
social shame for story it's a love story
I could not imagine somebody can make a
movie about the love story and Northcote
is no Romeo and Juliet and then when you
were Shakespeare was I never knew 18th
century 15th century 19th century people
wrote books I just hold [ __ ] through a
whole history is forgotten for nursing
people we are not allowed to know where
we are coming from
we just know that you are the people of
King's owner and kings
that's how to me was really shocking and
in the lobby there is no propaganda and
I could feel some case of freedom and
humanity I was very hungry and I
couldn't process anything after that
because I didn't have internet to check
what that was my life has been
unbearable because my father was a party
member but he got hours before his labor
business trading trading to China and he
sent to prison but here I have to
mention he is not criminal if he he was
born in this country
he didn't or more businessmen because he
was born in North Korea she saw the
server matter to China and it was
illegal and that's how he became
prisoner and he got tortured and he lost
his dignity but when he was in prison
though this discrimination is not the
level we can think of the prisoners even
can now look at the guards eyes because
they are not human beings so these
people are not human beings if when they
are in prison we hear that all our
political prison camps and here there a
lot is a labor camps in North Korea they
treated like people less
animals they treat their like normal
people outside alike best animals and
why they care about these prisoners and
that's how we done my father and also my
mama's okay interrogated and I lived
read up both of my parents at the age of
eight and my sister was 11 and I went to
two Reaver washing clothes and take bath
and go to mountain it grasshoppers
dragonflies plants anything I could get
from the nature that's why I said I bet
if I wasn't born North Korea I could be
Toria now but what can I do I have to
borrow gain in America that's how
serious this malnutrition is and I was
so surprised when I came to the West
often we describe spring as a season off
life we say spring when the life comes
back pink squirrel game by the North
Korea spring is a season of death nobody
take spring as his love life because
people suffer during the winter and they
cannot wait on chairs the summer the
plants girls and many people died in the
spring and that's why I have very sad
memory of a spring and and just it's so
different how we can ladies life and
only way I could live was going to China
I didn't know what was happening but I
knew if I go to China I'm not going to
die for the starvation in at the age of
13 and my sister was 15 she left to
China with her friend and though I she
left me we don't know that she said if
you go to find his lady they can help
you to go to China and that's how the
morning after I removed up pendeks
I think seven days later I could barely
walk with my mom
we found the lady and she told me we can
go to China that thing I didn't even
question why this your lady doing to
help us while this lady didn't ask money
you're just so desperate and
that's how we cross the frozen river in
2007 but I thought if I go to China I
didn't scare for freedom as I mentioned
that in no way means to be free
I skipped football or wise and once I
was in China I saw my mother weigh in
from my eyes and I was 13 years old and
they told me that if I will not be in
China we had to be sword and my mom
asked Amy what do you wanna do and I
thought I'm 13 years old and there are
nine human beings I was a merchandise
from that moment they are negotiating
pricing for mobiles and this is not
somebody I was unfortunate this is
typical story when those candy factors
are going to in China very personal
women being victimized by this human
trafficking so my mom was being to the
for $65 and I was there for $260 and it
reminds me you can item by your iPhone
without money in this country but that
somebody's life and that's wonders can
people think price for two people in
that living hair do people do nothing
wrong they were just boring dull in this
country I told you too hot our ears is
taking my mayor
ray enslavement the man who bought me
let me go and then I met try Christian
missionaries and they told me that for
the first time you can be free if you go
to South Korean and I asked I don't know
what it means three free so what you
mean I can be free and that person heard
you me you can rear jeans and you can
watch movies and freedom team us Bauer's
freedom not the freedom of speech not
the freedom of election just freedom as
very simple to me and at the water cool
and that's how we risk our life and walk
in a cost of freezing Gobi Desert in the
Lincoln nine in 2009 we had a little
compass with us
and we close and later we followed
northern spies to freedom and that's how
I became free it was it was my thousand
miles of journey to be free but I was
lying I had to cross another desert that
I had to start thinking for myself and
had I had to learn about this world I
was a time traveler I'll leave you that
is 24-hour electricity I never knew how
the airplane flies I thought they might
have wings or I didn't know how they are
flying and I didn't know what in a white
sauce I remember when I saw on TV when
I'm in South Korea I could not believe
people were talking about any more joy
and I like dah I'm like I didn't know I
had a wife in this country animal have
rights how big fun this world is and not
only that I had to learn about ATM
machine I had somebody into the machine
and give money to minutes and I learn
about polar hotties polar and what copy
machine what Americana is what the movie
theater is what is supermarket what's
online everything this learned from I
was a big order to baby who can tell who
can walk but you don't know anything and
that was very painful but not only that
people were for the first time started
asking me what do you think and never
had the privilege to use my free room I
never had the option to for me to choose
what I'm gonna wear
while going down study but people ask me
what do you know doing the future
what's your favorite color I didn't know
what I want to do and I was asking I was
hoping so I can tell me what I should do
for my life and then bananita
after her the lie I just lost her faith
in humanity I just can't risk anybody
again if what I believe in North Korea
that was her life how I trust again what
you're telling me is truth I just
couldn't do it
a day sad is not the Magna Buster's that
the Korean War
minsung started a and unknown they
cannot be true and the one book changed
in me and dollars George Orwell's Animal
Farm and to me was I just picked up blog
in the bookshelf I didn't know how do I
know what your jewelry is I thought this
book is gonna do MA about like animals
and I took the very same bow because I
didn't feel like I read a thick bow and
I just couldn't believe in because my
grandma was in that book my mother was
in that book and myself in that proving
the new piece and this guy explained
everything to me they showed me the path
of North Korean and deserving a present
of North Korean and I realized most
Korean people deserve what we deserve
here and what they are going to allow is
injustice if we say we believe in
justice how can we let this happen and
it's all about Holocaust how people get
executed for watching movies and why
these people now allow to learn these
books because if they are going on
screen these people is not different
they are just like us they have a whole
potential to be like a South Korean it's
too miss trouser is warm people but
after they had a different political
system what the [ __ ] is the most
developed IP country and the North Korea
the most darkest place on earth and we
should stop this and to me is like the
last say I often get to hear that I
think you really that bad
it cannot be true how come back so bad
it is really bad that's why we are not
allowed to collect contrary people
that's why the Hermit Kingdom and that's
why I'm telling my story that's why I
wrote this book I hope we can learn
something and we can do something about
this tragedy we have lots of things I
say before I had the things that youth
draw in this country
I've never scared and I'll never be
slave my father he passed away isn't in
other words of freedom and it
I've been China in the middle of nine I
couldn't even cry because I was scared
if somebody can hear me
as North Korean tupis life and being
sold and being cared and I hope you can
spread the word and let the word you
know
Vanakkam people can be free like us and
thank you so much for taking the time to
come to listen to myself thank you
[Applause]
I do canning on here I say anybody have
questions I'm very fond of going on
YouTube and looking at North Korean
videos that are posted and we always see
the North Korean people cheering madly
and crying weeping when they see their
grand leader and all like that
how much of that do you think is real
and how much is just because they know
they better do that it's a good question
and actually I wonder the same thing
when I was in North Korea and
everybody's watching each other and you
cannot trust each other we don't know
who the spies I can despite here and my
mother was also assigned to be a spy and
like I spy on you you spy on me
somebody's spy on her so we cannot
escape that process so you fight you two
don't report to you somebody's watching
me so I have to report you but if this
person doesn't watch like you report to
me that person's going to be punished
again so that kind of system everybody
is watching on each other they can be
spy and they can be spies and that's how
they keep is control in this country in
the spread of fear that's why we would
like to living in The Truman Show it was
nobody telling me the truth and I told
myself I didn't tell the truth later
I told nobody but I first really so I
don't know if these people use how to
clap survive they if they don't cry and
didn't climb they're going to get cured
and that's the afraid so even though
Syria or nah it's not why you people
don't clap they will get cured
it cannot be true and does I think all
the matter is not the question is I
really true or not but if these people
just do it they're gonna get cured and
they have to do it to survive so yeah
crazy here thank you
about what three years ago there was an
another author who co-wrote a book with
a guy by the name of shin who had a
scene yeah if they can't 14 yet have you
met him with my friend oh okay good oh
yeah it's doing any question about Bauer
just wondered if you had a chance to
contact him yet or oh yeah but but you
do yeah what he does or no a machine is
he just married and he or some American
bastard she's married American lady and
yes slightly living in freedom and lots
of difficulty as the activist and spoke
person but I think he's doing really
well
man thank you thank you what were the
circumstances went for the first time
you actually felt free oh thank you
I stared on the honestly what it means
to be free flee I think I'm learning is
every day and freedom is lots of things
I think freedom is everything for me it
was I found the freedom I became a human
being I can talk and I can think for
myself I thank you and I was able to
with the books I'd give all the book I
had to catch a relax of stuff I had to
know what the Middle East that's raw
memories and just I just had to really
to survive but then in South Korea
unless I'm not going to be able to talk
to you guys because I will be like alien
I will ask you what's Mars you know what
fun lies so I think it's just that
freedom and to me is like when I slide
Portland its freedom how would I imagine
I was going to take an airplane I didn't
know what passport was when I was in
North Korea I just didn't know traveling
freely was something a lot of for human
beings to do so just everything that we
do and if you have this voice yeah thank
you
I have a question about your English
which is quite good
where did you learn it and have you been
practicing and also I have another
question about what was the story with
your sister
mm-hmm losing my sister she came to us
after long 7 years ago and we met in
freedom again
so it's after Madhavi survived and we
carried on he never gave up and that's
how he was New Yorker so she is in
freedom and she is safe and for English
oh it's kind of mad bad and I watch the
American TV show friends mo it's like so
once you have 24 episodes and he has 10
season so 240 episodes it has it and if
you repeat that for at 30 times you
really have this English for sure very
very sure sign a lot of like 80s you
know 19 slang and people like this
written what's wrong video but yeah
that's how I use the the information
ability videos for this reason but
especially not in teaching English
becoming really the culture that we eat
turkeys for the Thanksgiving with kids
during in the New Year's Eve you know
all those kind of things so I really
like this when I'm here
I've read that a lot of North Korean
defectors once they got to South Korea
they felt a tremendous hostility towards
them meaning they weren't welcomed did
you feel did you have a state experience
amongst the South Koreans towards here
yeah it's kind of another trudging you
think okay you need to get North Korea
and us get China then South Korea then
everything with your wife okay no this
orders really hard to follow us and how
did you say that I think um I don't know
is very dilemma for me why South Koreans
they have so much things and they have
lots of African countries other
countries these papers not like they
don't have a compassion they have
compassion they have generosity and
kindness and but they have already
ignorant attitude to towards North
criminalization and there so I think
because of the Korean word the very
often think that I get is like once I go
to South Korea they'll also say that I
your spy they might destroy kobbari but
that's kind of big thing why you are
here I am spying and also logic is very
competitive society so they think we
come there and do their job and so we
increase the competition and also we are
the like less educated people so we
might be the potential terrorists and we
might be the we have like more like
higher cream crime rates and those kind
of stereotypes that you don't understand
the free market you just have a
mentality of calmness and you don't work
hard you are not trustworthy you don't
know anything and you have different
actions so if that's the kind of general
stereotypes against us so we also had to
fight there against again so my kids I'm
poor nobody I was from North Korea and
my university had to nobody to my
professors
I'm from South Korea and that's a way I
could survive again but things are
changing and not a right wrist ballet
but actually many people still have
those kind attitudes by hope your
changes in thank you so much for your
question has the regime tried to
discredit you and your story yeah I'm a
seen as done according to them and I'm a
poisonous mushroom that grew up in a bar
as a human like God is something they
really can say something very cruelly
and but not only that I have to the my
stories before
and last was October that was my first
time telling my story in Dublin and I
was not allowed to share my weight
I was late 13 years or the girl that
went through that and in South Korea the
purity and virginity is out everything
for a girl and I was tragic turn 22 on
that time and if I checked it what I
went through
they've not seen as a normal person and
I want to be somebody's mother to some
day and I always thought I have to hide
this to survive again but once I riding
to school I realized I have to tear the
whole story if not my shoe is not going
to have any power I have to tell the
whole story and that's how I put
everything down in the book Butler's
karidian came after me and they used all
my relatives back in North Korea and
they use the propaganda machine the
YouTube you can see my last tears and
all my neighbors are denouncing me that
I'm on Human Rights propaganda popped
out of the West
so obviously looking someone that
doesn't like me and he does everything
try to discredit me and spread the smear
campaigns against me so it's all five it
is a five and I'm
they're not free he's trying to steer
try to control me in that disappoint
when I just had a question
mm-hmm so you said you didn't know how
many in North Korea how many other
countries there what more North Korean
maps like the question mm-hmm so thank
when you are talking about poverty I
think there is a different level of
poverty when I say how polio is not the
way how I can describe any for example
we have like one cancer and we don't use
it because it's very very valuable for
us it's very hard to have a one pen sir
and we have one textbook and then you
rewrite it and rewrite it and write
again and erase it again and that's real
poverty means and you will never imagine
the textbook can be colored one textbook
won't last hazard and it's like really
really old and everybody's their
mother's company for their textbook and
that's how is it so there's no way I can
I didn't never see no desert so that's
the first moment is a nicer desert Wow
it's or sun's setting so see the photos
of desert and that's how things are not
there if we don't have color the photos
or gloves
I think it's Tanya is different that
only people but the country we are
really portable living that's real
poverty means
forgive this question do you feel safe
do you feel safe when you're traveling
in the United States or overseas no I
guess I'm Jenny two years old and after
that I feel like I live a thousand years
literally I saw so many things then what
humans can inflict to each other and I
saw the salvation and kindness but the
worst thing we can do each other and I
lived in a very lots of different
countries and I was a slave where my own
free press now so it feels like my life
now it's all kind of almost extra life I
think you understand somebody who faced
death several times you feel like it's
extra life and unfortunately that's my
case so like North Korea Jim send a
Cessna Japan to my fellow key factors in
South Korea who's trying to get the
information says North Korea and it
scares me I'm like working with them and
like I see the newest also she had pants
over there and that is and they those
collisions are actually trying to
contact with me and that but I guess you
know the freedom is not free so we have
to pay price for that and so thank you I
[Music]
think you and can you speak a little bit
as how you got involved with the
nonprofit Liberty in North Korea
Oh actually my working with them by was
helping my family some like project that
they were working on with the and modern
generation so and they also invited me
to speak up there are so many so I only
actually like not really engage your
inaudible is really supporting their
work so I was trying to do the campaign
online to rescue people yeah
so it's I know it's a clear path in
South Korea see now yeah so that's how I
met negative working North Korea thank
you I was wondering do you ever miss
anything and what is love or dating like
in North Korea normal Dame's like do you
miss do you miss anything about North
Korea and what is it like if you love
someone or you're dating someone in
North Korea
yeah I hope this can be a fun part I
really hope is I feel bad when I took
honors Chris very dark so imagine you
don't have all these lights and you
don't have this big giant buildings and
you don't have all the music you don't
have any technology sound
you only hear the sound a human can make
with their child is flicking in there
washing dishes and they are cooking it
they are talking to each other and
that's how it's not as clear almost like
it is time has stopped and it's not even
moving
but in that stillness and you can have
very close continent connection that you
have to talk to each other but if
nothing is there we don't have any toys
the children have to bring all your
parents and parents have does not
comprehend smart foreign books so they
help to to their children so that's
really I'm a SAP on North Korea by human
intimacy
and I think breathing live was my mother
got married to my father
and they're both parent aside to let
them get married and they didn't even
hold hands before they get married and I
asked my mom now why did you get married
and she told me I just didn't hate him
so so it's a kind of like fight for love
you know I love you my like romance
I never knew my romance was and I never
knew we have nowhere to go on date we
have a coffee shops movie theater we
have something go and I just recently
read the article and it just broke my
heart
understand effect you're a guy who
escaped and could keep dreaming take his
drive to a Shore Drive we never can
imagine on a car in North Korea and
that's his dream and I drove I meant why
today like for several times and that
can be somebody's dream that's what he's
living for he's working really hard
himself and to write to make money and
bring his wife to the stuff and then he
wants to take his wife to a drive and
that's our dream and I think that's
North Korea that we don't have luxury to
think about moments we don't have
romantic novel we just have nothing but
I guess some people fall in love but we
don't know we can say I love you so we
can say like mr. Conrad you know for
today all I think you can't go somewhere
I thank you because we don't have
friends in North Korea
everybody's comrade and everybody's
revolutionary and that's more like our
woman I think performance yeah I said
more questions or you can step yes so
when you're in high fan you had a boy
that was infatuated with you and never
you heard anything from him since the
book was complete no his father went to
prison camp and I don't even know his
share life so that's our lives just many
people are missing and there's nobody to
find those people mostly I can go back
home someday and find all my friends
thank you so much for your question
thank you
oh okay have a wonderful evening and I
hope we can really enjoy the process
[Applause]
that if you want to buy a book the tails
will be shutting down at about 8:45 and
you're welcome to go downstairs and buy
it and come back up
okay
Thank You book TV